carlos bustamante with ET canada nobody
else nobody else got musical instruments
for the Oh Canada the extraterrestrials
of Canada
yeah people always think it's
Entertainment Tonight but it's not
always yeah um guys this is exciting for
a lot of reasons you're both pretty big
part of heads right I've been here
anytime I ask anyone who's the biggest
part of head as always
Ezra has a fandom for you gotten bigger
are you cynical at all yeah even bigger
even better bigger better yeah I'm so
excited do I communicate as people keep
asking us to do it in words it's so hard
I just want to take all my clothes off
and hate myself all the different
Hogwarts colors and just you know yeah
like make out like with one of these
right statues like muscle man from the
circle contest that would communicate
how I feel yeah but I can't do that
we're doing a press junket this is very
optional we're talk about it so yeah
it's very exciting yeah yeah so fandom
is huge obviously for for this move for
the whole universe but it can be a
double-edged sword there are people
online that before even seeing the film
kind of start bashing it like what's
what are your thoughts on that
oh yeah that's wild man we live in wild
times they just did without even having
an opportunity to see the whole film
money what we're like we'll say
something we'll be okay wait to see the
film and they're like no and you're like
what oh okay
I mean look it's just a suggestion yeah
I know take it or leave it everyone has
the right to express all the feelings
they want at all times and I really
value that think that's vital and
important yeah that's the whole premise
you know mind like what our societies
are supposed to look like and they don't
enough at all
so people should be free to say whatever
they want at whatever time I'm just
suggesting why don't you wait to look at
a piece of art before you critique it is
usually that's like how critics do it
right of course they like wait to see it
then they critique it and then we'll
hear your critiques and
try to make the next one even better
although I must say I think once you see
the film you'll see what I mean it's
quite good it's quite rich to learn more
about that you're a Harry Potter fan
you're gonna lose your mind if you're
not Harry Potter if and you're gonna
lose your mind yeah and you're gonna be
like I need to read Harry Potter because
this I don't know what this is but it's
not the kids stuff I thought it was it
is terrifying and it is awesome
that's hardcore it's cool yeah sexy
bunny it's cute but it's also one of the
scariest movies ever seen
so I mean who is cuter for you in in the
film
Ezra or the NIF lers esident Ezra Ezra
because he is everything everything
isn't it's one person how difficult it
is it is the same way equality is like a
living Scamander case you got everything
and it's all of it inside yeah
how difficult is it to just like be in
the world with your friends and they're
just hounding you about questions like
what happens next is this character
really related to that character they've
got all their theories is a difficult
feat of silence cuz we're always their
friends and they're like one of us
definitely I'm sorry I just can't I yeah
man it's so hard you know yeah thank you
yeah
really have hard lives yeah it's really
hard it's hard life is tough right life
is tough so go watch a movie Rainey a
secret right yeah no that is hard no
being a secret keeper is real sometimes
challenging right at work but also I
wouldn't go ahead and be like yet so you
know cuz we all do these interviews to
complain yeah of course man this is like
so exciting we're like the most most
people ever and we're just excited for
people to see the movie because it's so
dank I'm excited for you this is
everything thanks so much thank you